So far, we've learned how to acquire
data sets and format the data fields.
We've also learned how to identify and
clean dirty data and
how to reshape the data
sets into the form we need.
You'll need to think
about these ideas and
apply them to nearly every
data set you use for analysis.
However, you rarely
would just have one file
that has all the data you need in it.
You're going to want to use as much
data as is relevant to your analysis.
That data may come from
different places, and
as a result, it'll all need to be
stitched together into one data file.
This is what we call data blending.
And it can be done in many ways.
In this lesson, we will learn how to
blend data through Unions, Joins,
Fuzzy Matching, and by Spatial Matching.